my name is tangai theresa and my name is
jack houston
and hi i'm jenna malone hello i'm lily
cold hey i'm janelle monae
and we are the cast of antebellum and we
are going to be playing the game
whose food
who's most likely to break character
during a take
i think you too i think you're much more
yes
coming into this and i'm like wide eye
man i'm like oh my god this is jack man
i saw you in this and and i saw you in
that and and
oh my gosh it's janelle like so i'm kind
of like all giddy
lily and here's why i say lily because
once you watch antebellum you'll realize
that lily and also uh shout out to
gabbaree
those two are so fun their improv
would go so many ways actually i'm gonna
say me and then i would break character
because i'm laughing
who's most likely to forget their lines
i feel like some of us are an unfair
disadvantage
because i didn't get to work with
everyone so i feel like every time i'm
just going to be looking at you janelle
and be like
so who did you think it was say me yeah
maybe i would say
you know actually i might say um jack
actually
he had a lot of lines i remember there
would be like whole
things that he had to just go through i
think maybe me man
i don't know because sometimes i don't
know why sometimes i just go off
i think you were you're so well prepared
and you were so honest sometimes i'd be
like
i said what i was meant to say just in a
very different way
who is most likely to be caught taking a
selfie
man you already know that's jack like
all day buddy
you know why i say that play with your
mustache
i think i did take a few selfies in it
just to sort of
look at myself and stare in horror
you're both so beautiful
i would take pictures of myself if i
were you but i'm gonna go ahead and say
i was probably the one taking selfies
because this is my first feature film
and i could not believe that i was on
set
with janelle and gabby who's most like
their character
i don't think either of us are like our
characters absolutely
i don't know i mean i feel like i think
in a sense maybe i most like my
character
and only only because of the people
who inspire my character their
inspirations of mine as well
who is most likely to be the rebel of
their friend group
well i feel like janelle i feel like you
are just a rebel of
the world you just listen to the
revolutionary not just
you know yes exactly and jenna i can see
you also being
a super rebel you know for sure same for
you
lily i think like i know for me i want
to go and explore where nobody is gone
i don't think we we know each other's
friend groups well enough no
i think we're both rebels man we're
rebels of the ark brother there you go
who's most likely to nail a stunt on the
first
try i mean i do a lot on the horse i
mean i was in a lot of stump works there
you go
tonga would probably be more likely to
nail a physical stunt with himself
i'm more likely to nail a stunt where
it's involving
a large beast i have no idea what i
would have done if they put me on a
horseman i think i'm definitely gonna
say janelle i remember having some
pretty incredible stunts with you
listen you don't want to get in in a in
a in a fight
with this one jenna goes there thank you
jen thank you lily
uh for for joining and just bringing
something that
allowed me to be fearless that allowed
me to to be fun when i needed to be
to be serious and sad and to fight when
i needed
to fight
you